hello everyone and welcome to game four
of the second semi-final match between
magnus carlson and yanni ponishi
and uh so far things have been going uh
excellent for
jan and he's been winning he won the
first match he won the second game of
the second match and then magnets
retaliated in game three winning his
first game of
the the match altogether and now uh nepo
is in a position where he needs a draw
or a win in the final game to go into
the finals
and magnus needs a win uh just the first
break so magnets with the white pieces
let's see what happened here as this is
uh well it's quite
the short one so magnus opened with e4
we have c5 the sicilian defense
knight f3 we have d6 and now d4 so
nothing out of the ordinary here
captures captures in the knight to f6 uh
we have knight to c3 and a6
and nipple goes for the knight of
variation of the sicilian with
a4 controlling that b5 square and e5 now
chasing away the knight we have knight
back to f3
and h6 so napo going for a a very solid
system
g3 magnus ready to find his light square
bishop and bishop to e7
we have bishop to g2 and here there is
one game where bishop to e6 was played
in no doubt magnus knows this because it
was a game
that anish giri played against yanni
ponychi and he defeated him so probably
jan
uh studied how how he went wrong in that
game but here
uh jan deviates by playing at castles
and tries to tries to surprise magnus
with this move
and it is definitely a new move in the
position already as
of move nine so here uh we have castles
by magnus
uh and bishop to e6 only now uh and
knight to h4 going after that f5 square
and the unplayed knight b to d7 here
pretty automatically preparing knight to
c5
uh but this is actually a mistake maybe
not a mistake but
uh as you as you'll see how the game
turns out uh
it could very well be a mistake here uh
best is just to go bishop to g4 and this
is a weird move to play but you're
attacking the queen
and you're asking what do you what do
you want to do here and now we could
either see something like f3 and then
white's king's position has been weak
and we
continue from that or we go into bishop
f3 and maybe go for some sort of a
repetition here so this
is uh this is all in the position and
very interesting uh but nipple went for
knight b to d7 and now
knight to f5 for magnus of course this
knight is too strong it's a monster
knight we have to eliminate it
captures captures and now queen to c7 by
nipple preparing to bring the rooks over
to the c
file put pressure on the c2 pawn at
least the knight will not be able to
move so here
a5 by magnus not allowing this knight
to come to b6 also if b5 then a capture
captures on b6 alpha sound will be
played bishop to e3 is coming
controlling b6
so very um nicely played so rook a to b8
preparing to push the b
pawn but magnus stops it with bishop to
e3
uh we have rook f the c8 and now queen
to d3 and already
you can see that the position is not
easy to play for black especially with
white controlling the d5 square so
nicely you don't have d5 and
as you know when you don't have d5 as
black it's very very hard to play
so bishop to fade by on and magnus goes
rook after c1 now the knight will be
able to move as the c2 pawn is very well
defended
so b6 uh jan decides to give up some
material
to try and uh bust open the position so
a captures on b6
knight captures and now rook captures an
a6
now we have knight to c for now with a
double attack on the b2 pawn
also pressuring the bishop here but now
knights the d5 by magnus putting
pressure on the queen and
and the knight here and if you capture
the knight then bishop captures and e5
is very strong
if knight captures for example an e3
queen captures and real captures on b2
then rook to a7 is extremely strong uh
you cannot block the bishop covers b7
and once the queen moves we're gonna
capture on f7
so this is carlson's idea so after
knight to d5 nip
needs to go back he cannot capture on d5
he plays queen to d8
and now b3 just chasing away that knight
knight
captures queen captures and rook the c5
now
now nepo is putting resistance here but
he is down upon and the magnus does have
a past
b pawn and it's only moved 22. so c4
cementing that knight on d5 also the
queen is nicely guarding the b3 pawn
and queen to c8 now putting pressure on
the rook on a6
uh but now also pressuring if you move
the rook you could run into knight
capture spawn captures and then you lose
the rook on c1
so here magnus goes for this force line
knight captures on f6 with
check g captures and now rook to a7
and now what do you do bishop is coming
to d5 f7 will
will be pressured you only have a dark
square bishop you have no knights you
cannot defend the df7 square which is a
light square
and nippon knows this he goes queen
captures on f5
and now bishop to d5 and there is no
good way to defend this uh we have queen
to g5 offering a queen
trade and magnus says sure i'm just
going to play rook to b1 prepare to push
my b
pawn as well nipple trades here captures
captures and
rook to b for now so stopping those
pawns but now
bishop captures an f7 with check king to
h8
and now bishop back to d5 and
rook the c8 you have to uh guard the the
back rank but it's not really helping
and look at
look at nipples bishop nepo's bishop is
the is the definition of a bad bishop
it's a dark square bishop hemmed in by
his own pawns and dark squares
it's not going anywhere uh anytime soon
so here king g2 by magnus
rook c the b8 putting pressure on the b3
pawn
but now rook to f7 now if everything
gets traded off on b3 then of course
rook captures on f8 is coming
so bishop to g7 by nippo and here magnus
just played rook to a1
and it was in this position that uh jani
pony should resign the game and
magnus wins two straight games in a row
bounces back and forces tie breaks
incredible
uh as it is but he he did it
uh the the madman did it and uh it's
i mean it's amazing i didn't even ask
you to pause the video here because
there was no
position where i could have asked you to
pause the video i mean after that
uh slight inaccuracy let's call it that
in the beginning of the game
uh where magnus was able to trick nepal
with this
preparation with this knight stay h4
move
if you don't find bishop to g4 it
doesn't seem like you're gonna have a
lot of fun in this game by allowing
knight to f5
uh magnus got uh so much out of the
position so
there was no pause the video moment to
even give you it was just uh you know
the position deteriorated onto itself
so after this work day one magnus wins
and now we are going into tie breaks uh
so uh you know stay stay tuned for that
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank mr
hoody guy connor watts david kimura
nicolas verkos and peter smith for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day